50 washington dc
the zip code 2001
next actor and comedian jerry lewis
addresses the national press club
the 69 year old lewis talked about his
relationship with the press and his
broadway debut
he's currently appearing on broadway in
the musical damn yankees
his speech and the question and answer
period run about 55 minutes
[Music]
good afternoon
good afternoon and welcome to the
national press club
my name is monroe carmen
i am president of the press club
and editor-at-large at bloomberg
business news
i'd like to welcome our club members and
their guests
in the audience today as well as
those of you watching on c-span or
listening to this program on national
public radio
or the global internet computer network
before
introducing our head table
i would like to remind our listeners
of upcoming speakers on tuesday april
18th tomorrow we will hear from
republican presidential candidate
governor lamar alexander of tennessee
on
wednesday april 19th
marine explorer jean-michel cousteau
will talk about
the search for sustainability
and on thursday april 20th carol browner
administrator of the
environmental protection agency will
talk about
quote the earth is in your hands
responsibility and opportunity
in the new generation of environmental
protection
transcripts and
audio and visit and videotapes of press
club luncheons
are available by calling 1-800-500-9911
that's 1-800-500-9911
if you have any questions for our
speakers please
write them on the cards at your table
pass them up to me
and i will ask as many as time permits
and now i would like to
introduce our head table
from your right roger anderson scripps
howard news service
please stand briefly when your names are
called jill tucker
agency france press
john price knight ridder tribune news
service
sabrina eaton cleveland plain dealer
jeff lowe mr lewis's manager
uh skipping over our
speaker claudia cummins bloomberg
business news and the member of the
national press club speakers committee
who arranged today's luncheon
in fine style i might add thank you
jason weinberg mr lewis's publicist
ann oldenburg usa today
hal hinson of the washington post
and dan moreau of kiplinger washington
editors
and i want to thank a special thanks to
melissa bender pat nelson melanie abdo
dermot and jeff tarbell
all of whom
played a major role in organizing
today's luncheon
it is a singular pleasure for me
to introduce today's guest speaker
he's been a hero of mine since boyhood
when i was in high school
[Music]
when i was in high school
martin and lewis were the hottest comedy
actor around did you hear we split up
yeah
my best friend and i decided if martin
and lewis could do it so could cats and
carmen we formed our own comedy act and
we were good very very good
really we would have turned professional
except for our sinus problem
no one would sign us
okay that's it
it's designed to make you look
uh seriously we brought jerry lewis here
for a special reason
as you know the balanced budget
amendment failed in congress
now democrats and republicans are
arguing
over i'm still laughing at the last joke
are arguing over how to reduce the
federal budget deficit
well i have a suggestion for them
jerry lewis has collected nearly 1
billion in box office receipts over the
years
his most popular films include the bell
boy cinderfella and the nutty professor
for melanie
[Applause]
he also has raised 1.4 billion dollars
for his favorite charity
the crusade against muscular dystrophy
and he's done it all
without increasing taxes
read my lips no tax increase
so my suggestion why not give jerry
lewis the floor of the congress and let
him conduct a telethon for just one
session he could wipe out the federal
debt single-handedly
born joseph levich in 1926
he was the child of professional
entertainers
at the age of 20
jerry joined with dino crocetti better
known as dean martin to form one of the
most famous comedy teams of all time
after the team broke up in 1956 he i got
that in there
mr lewis went on to establish his
credentials
as a single
he's been called
quote the last of the classic bodilians
unquote
matter of fact he's even more popular
abroad
particularly in france than he is in
this country he's been named best
director in that country three times
he's been inducted into the legion of
honor
he's been made a commander in the order
of arts and letters
the french minister of culture called
him
a child's friend
and a model for adults
mr lewis
excuse me is no stranger to washington
he was a member of president john f
kennedy's fun circle
he's been honored by the senate for his
crusade against muscular dystrophy
in 1985 the defense department awarded
him the medal for distinguished public
service
mr lewis has five sons and several
grandchildren he and his wife sam have a
young daughter danielle
jerry's most recent movie funny bones
was released by disney in march
he's now playing satan
in the broadway revival of damn yankees
a role that the new york times said
makes him
quote legitimate at last
uncle
ladies and gentlemen we've heard from
democrats we've heard from republicans
they've all reported their views on the
first 100 days of the new congress
now let's hear a different perspective
from our guest jerry lewis
[Applause]
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
that was a lovely introduction bud i
thought i was at my own funeral
when
pardon me when i was first contacted by
the national press club which was
about a year or so ago
i wasn't available to come here and i
had written to the individual that had
written to me stating that the moment i
can make it i would be truly honored
to be present at the national press club
now before i get into the why of that
when they knew i was coming today the
press department for the national press
club called and said what is your title
of your speech
and i said my life as a viking
i didn't know i needed a goddamn title
to come here and talk
but in spite of what bud said i need for
you to know that i do not get into
politics i do comedy already
[Applause]
i have a strong point of view
i'm a serious-minded man
i do some of the most ridiculous absurd
physical comic things that have ever
been seen by the human condition
while i do have a point of view i have
strong beliefs i think politics belong
where they belong i think humor should
be more a part of politics indeed
we'd be able to swallow some of it much
more easily
i truly believe that um
newt gingrich
just look at his initials
now
only because i think public broadcasting
is a magical
important communication in this country
today
i have a three-year-old daughter and i'm
proof positive and looking at the
excellence of this child's brain
and watching the beauty of her
formative years she speaks in three
languages
though not totally
she does her abcs in french hebrew and
english she got that from public
broadcasting her understanding of
animals the kingdom the world
she got from nova
she got an awful lot from her mother and
father
but any chance i get
to put public broadcasting where it
belongs
as a priority in the foreground of our
lives i do that
that's the end of the commercial
i will go forward now if you could raise
the volume a little bit i won't have to
get quite as close to the microphone i'd
appreciate that
al alec
electrician do you mind if i just get
well it's not as bad as yours bud
an interesting
commentary in that when i was asked to
do damn yankees
i had a
i had a very very strong
difficult time wrestling with making
that decision
primarily because i had never been on
broadway and i felt that if i was going
to do broadway
it would have to be
absolutely
primo
the show is that
the show was a spectacular show and
anyone fortunate enough to be placed in
that show is very very lucky
but i felt that i was
69 years going to be 69 years old
eight shows a week
and i had just come back from london
and i did a film called funny bones
where the director wanted very much for
me
to put on weight
so that i would look more mature and
elderly and so on
i complied happily
i had steak and eggs for breakfast in
carling's brew at 10 in the morning and
then at lunch we'd have a lager and then
we would have wonderful dinners with a
vodka or two and then a fine wine along
with and i put on
about 34 pounds and i was up to 200
pounds
now when damn yankee said we would like
you to do this
i said there's no chance in hell i'm
ever going to be the devil at 200 pounds
i said i will consider it if
you will allow me
three months to lose the weight learn
the book learn the songs come to new
york prepared and ready
for the first time in the history of
broadway the producers went to the
unions who gave them permission to shut
the show down
while i
worked on the treadmill
i stayed under 800 calories a day
i worked the treadmill five miles every
morning five miles every evening i
played with my daughter which was equal
to the 10 miles on the treadmill
and i had to get a focus
probably for the first time in my life i
needed a focus
of infinite care within my own brain
which included
making a total complete turnaround with
the press
to deal with them differently to
recognize that they were part of this
pattern that i was getting into
i was going to sell the show
i was going to be the best
the best guest on any television show
the best one-on-one with reporters
i turned around my whole point of view
which was all part of the focus i lost
the weight i'm happy to proclaim i'm 166
pounds i'm having the best time i did
127 one-on-ones in the last 12 weeks
i did 63 electronic press
i'm doing phil donahue tomorrow morning
for two hours
i'm doing two hours of a e and they're
doing a two-hour biography that i did
with dateline and i'm still going
the point i'm making here is now the
national press club invites me to come
there
well it's the first time i could
acknowledge that invitation and come
happily proudly
and with a full heart
i cannot remember
feeling quite this good about having
anything to do with the press in a long
long time
and the conversion is a wonderful one
because it's serving me so well
i feel so good about it i feel so good
about
the focus that i have been
on now i walk out on that stage
and it's like the parting of the red sea
these audiences are absolute one they're
either thrilled that i'm making it
or they're delighted that there isn't i
see you waiting for me
or that i'm just getting through with
the show but whatever the hell it is
they stand up every show and they're
screaming and carrying on like the
goddamn beatles were out there
and i'm getting all of the benefits of
this
the only down time for me is monday when
we don't have a damn show
my daughter recognizes what's happening
with me
she sees that i'm having the time of my
life and now i find that i've become a
role model
for men who are considering retiring at
55
why an atrophy
look at what i'm doing i'm going to be
on the national tour for my 70th
birthday
we'll be in baltimore on my 70th
birthday
then we finish the national tour after a
year of damn yankees and we do the film
for warner brothers which takes us to
june of 97.
then in july of 97 we opened in london
for a year which takes us to june of 98
we go to paris from july 98 till the
first month of 99 and then go to berlin
for the balance of the year so i'm
booked
and having the time of my life
i got on a train today on my day off
to come to the national press club
if you told me that 10 years ago i shot
you
it's incredible
but i came because i wanted this
platform
i wanted to be able to say to the press
i need you as badly as you need me
and working together is a joy
now i'm getting letters from the
interviewers there's a wonderful writer
that writes for interview magazine in
new york
he sent me flowers to my dressing room
with a lovely card for the one on one we
did for two hours
then i called him his name's graham
fuller i called him i said graham you
don't understand it was me that had all
the fun
it was wonderful for me to be this
good about what i was doing
he said yeah i noticed that the angry
man wasn't there anymore
i said well i had reasons for that i'll
give you a case in point
a reporter in chicago some years ago
went to see a film that was my baby i
wrote it produced it acted in it
and went through labor pains with it
prior to its opening i sent out what i
thought was tiffany-like packages
of information about the film
stills of the film
the film was called which way to the
front it was a great satire
on the hitler years in germany and it
was great comedy
and this newspaper man
reviewed the film in chicago
and reviewed a scene that i had cut out
after we sent this material out
i did a preview after i sent all the
publicity packets out and at the preview
i was concerned with that sequence it
really wasn't working i deleted the
eight-minute sequence
he reviewed it from the information that
was in the in the folder he never saw
the film
he broke my heart
because i felt that was dirty
and unfair and not really professional
so when you talk about an angry man i'm
carrying some anger from about 100 of
those
but then you get the joy of knowing that
you shake hands and you have a
friendship with jack anderson
and the likes of those kinds of men
i'm proud to stand here and say to you
that edward r murrow and i had a
meaningful relationship as friends
walter cronkite i always wish was my
father
so for the bad guys in your racket
we got some bad guys in our racket
but isn't it nice to find out that 98
are terrific
and that the two percent are interesting
to talk about but they're meaningless
i sound like norman vincent peale all of
a sudden
anyhow the eight ruling shows
are terrific
what people don't remember is that when
dean and i played the paramount theater
we did 56 shows a week
we played there for two weeks it was
and twelve shows
they ran an hour and ten minutes each
show
we then went to the chicago theater and
performed nine a day which is 63 shows
in the three weeks we performed
175 shows in 21 days now i'm at the
press conference at sardi's
and the reporter yells how are you going
to handle a gruelling eight shows a week
i said i did 175 shows in 21 days he
said but you were 20 years old
i said so i'm 69 i'm only doing eight
that works for me
i just hope you get a chance to see the
show
because it's a marvelous company
and i've been playing the devil for 64
years i had my first tuxon at the age of
five performed with my mom and dad i was
as mischievous then as i am now
but this role
was written
with this devilish character and when i
went to see it last october to see if i
wanted to go with it i was amazed that i
hadn't remembered i've been playing this
character 64 years it's perfect
now i get people coming backstage saying
when did they write that show for you
which is not the case of course but it's
wonderful oh i have to tell you this
there's another very important thing
here coming here at this time of the
year i really want you to know how
important it was to me this is the high
holy holidays in case you're interested
and in my faith the high holy holidays
nothing moves
everything stands still
in the high holy holidays
so i have to tell you this incident
and the high holy holidays in the jewish
faith people stay home and they cook and
they're with family they don't travel
they don't spend money they don't do
anything
well i knew this jewish rabbi what other
kind of rabbi well i knew this rabbi
he loved to play golf
so much
it was better than breathing for him
and it's the high holy holidays
and this rabbi sneaks out to the country
club
tees up the ball and it's a five par
hole tees up his ball
and he's going to play golf saint peter
is watching this
saint peter says god could you come here
for a second
god walked over and saint peter said
take a look god looked and said don't
worry i'll take care of everything
when you tell it you use yours when i
tell it
so saint peter said god this is
unconscionable a man of the cloth about
to play golf on the high holy holidays
god said watch in a second you'll see
this the rabbi hits this ball on this
five par
525 yards the ball flies
525 yards lands on the green and it
rolls into the cup saint peter looks at
god and said god what kind of punishment
is that god said who's he going to tell
[Applause]
you know for years we've been doing
polish jokes
and people forget
that it started way before that
it started in the 1900s i'm
i'm sharing information with you that i
learned from my dad
there were irish jokes
they were the jokes
the italian jokes they were the jokes
way before the pollock jokes
the black jokes
lutheran jokes
christian jokes
confessional jokes
incredible how the wheel turns i don't
know who's getting it next
what pollocks are in now
as you know
and the interesting thing is that if we
didn't have
humor to defuse the lives we lead
in the world we're functioning in
we'd be in far greater trouble than we
are
humor diffuses the pressure
people cannot
be in pain while laughing we have found
that pain will cease and desist while a
good laugh is happening in the body
that's of course why the academy of
motion picture arts and sciences don't
even have a category for comedy but i
won't get into that now
so if you can defuse the pain and
pressure of every day's life
with humor
it's so marvelous
and people have to stop being
how can i use this expression and still
be diplomatic people have to stop being
so tight
about offended
being offended
a polock joke is probably laughed at
more by the pollock than anyone else
the jew thought it was a wonderful joke
if the humor was there
and we do things now in our business
there are of course 9 000 stand ups in
our country today
6 000 of whom should sit down but we do
have
we do have some wonderful young
performers we've got performers that are
taking some of the ethnic humor
and devising wonderful comic tones with
it
and doing visual things i give you robin
williams as a perfect example the
brilliance
of robin williams and everything he does
touches on ethnic humor touches on
everything
but he's fast enough that you don't
really see it
he's so brilliant with his visual
comic ability that you don't see exactly
where all of his nonsense is coming from
billy crystal is a little smoother about
it
steve martin's a little smoother about
it whoopi goldberg is very aggressive
about it but we've got great talents out
there what i am
displeased with is the young comic that
stands up
in a small room
and he now prepares cerebral combat
he's going to challenge this audience to
hear what he has to say
well you don't say to your friends let's
go and hear this comedian you usually
say let's go see him
well what are you going to go see audio
you should be seeing visual
so i say to the young comics
move move your body you can tell the the
rabbi joke by moving all over the
country club
just make it visual
so they listen to me because i'm the
elder statesman now
and they're
what are you choking about i am
no no no no no you have to be delighted
about it i learned that age really
resents the fact that you're delighted
about it
when you're delighted about it for some
reason age looks and says oh christ i'm
going to get someone else
it's wonderful to challenge it and get
up every day and say i'm going to be the
minute i was 69 i'm telling everybody
i'm going to be 70.
it's wonderful
and my wife says why are you rushing it
i said i can't rush the calendar but i
can talk about it it's a wonderful thing
to be able to i made 70.
jesus with the way people drive today
you know what i had in mind oh i have to
tell you shirley mclean came to see the
show
and she had a wonderful time she comes
backstage and she told me that i'm 526
years old and i worked with da vinci for
10 years then we broke up
an idea that i had
i want to open a franchise of eulogy
stores
where you can walk in off the street and
for twenty dollars they'll read you all
the wonderful things they're gonna say
about you after your croak
wouldn't that be a marvelous chain of
eulogy stores i love that
okay
i've talked at uh
1700 universities around the world
in the last 25 years
a hundred different cinema classes and
maybe 5 000 acting cinema and film
classes around the world
and it's always interesting to me
when we do open forum primarily i i
always say to the group that i'm
speaking to that i'm not standing there
as a qualified anything i'm there
uh sharing
my life and all the things that i've
i've experienced and we get into
sessions and it's an it's incredible how
young people want to pull from you and
their their curiosity is so incredible
at some times you do four hours you
don't know where four hours went and
it's just back and forth question and
answer
and i had a menu
and i would read to the students now
here's where we can go
film
directors state-of-the-art sound
state-of-the-art video broadway france
the economy
the media
humanities
culture world humor
medicine
travel business
judgito
unions
marcia clark's hair
the elderly poverty in america
communications giving
community service parenting
when you give a group that kind of a
menu to choose from to talk about
and then a card comes up
and it reads
did you ever fool around with marilyn
monroe
it's a little depressing
but it's interesting because there's a
curiosity there so you answer it to the
best of your ability and you hopefully
get out with your skin still intact but
i like i watched i told but i watched uh
the national press club on c-span
whenever i could when i was home
particularly it's on at 10 o'clock in
las vegas
and i love watching it yet i'm intrigued
by the cards
that the president of the club will read
to the guests
and getting comments from the guests
from the cards i'm waiting for that
that's my most favorite time
can we do that bud
i can't wait
because it's really intriguing to me at
what comes up
and the interesting thing is you don't
know what it's going to be therefore
it's an exercise
see what you're going to come up with
what your answers are are you credible
is it honest
are you going to deal in theatrics are
they expecting you to be a buffoon
do they truly want to know that
is it important is it worthwhile is it
meaningful and all of that stuff goes
through your mind when you do that
how do you do it how do you do it buddy
i've never seen you sort of step up here
like this yes you hold this card there
it's blank in other words
i'm working with a guy again is that it
i can't sing okay
mr lewis you have brought so much
laughter and enjoyment to myself and
others
what can we do to bring movies and tv
back to clean
non-violent
entertainment well i don't think that
it's going to take a committee of people
to change the structure of a film that
will do 267 million dollars how do i say
to that producer that's
that's violent
it's not good for our children
he's just bought a home in
san carbo
bobby lucas whatever you call that
he's very very happy with his roles and
he's certainly not going to change his
lifestyle he's going to listen to me say
to him this is not good for the children
of america
but you have to remember that there are
films out there
like
free willy
there's a producer there
that cares about what your children
think
for that matter what the children's
family thinks
there are producers that make
good work there are people that do nova
on pbs
we've got great filmmakers that are
doing great work
this is a generalization what can we do
about non-violent and family-like
entertainment
we've got a lot of it
we're talking about maybe the seven or
ten percent of the product that isn't
what we really think it should be but on
the whole
and i may sound defensive but i love my
industry on the whole i think we do some
good work
you cannot forget the stephen
spielberg's of the world
you cannot forget schindler's list
if we forgot it it would have been a
waste
that's quality and our children will
learn from that
and there's a lot more i could name
that are important works done by by
important producers
who will be
ultimately who will be the messenger to
the other producers ultimately one day
when they see their products not going
to move they're going to change
that's bound to happen because i have
seen it in all of the years that i've
been performing the quality comes to the
top
and the credibility is like cream and a
bottle of milk it always comes to the
top
so i have a great faith and trust in our
in our system
not government necessarily but our
system
why do you think the french
have an even greater appreciation of
your talent and genius than the people
of your own country
well i think there's a misnomer there i
think that the people of my country have
given me tremendous longevity they've
been there for me every moment of my
entire life
this has been a misnomer in that the
french critics
have hailed my work
as exceptional and i'm proud of that
but the truth is that spain italy
germany
belgium the netherlands
japan and australia are far greater
jerry lewis fans than than the french
but the french have gotten all the
publicity because americans are down on
the french so often
and they love this combination they like
this pratfall jewish comedian well what
does that tell you
but that's okay that's okay there's
politics there's politics in everything
the truth is that the american people
have given given me 64 years of their
love and affection and i've given it
back
and that this is where i live
number one is here
france can be two
go ahead bub
from your experience can you assess
the value to the arts community of the
national endowment for the arts
can i assess the value yeah to the arts
community in general
of the national endowment for the arts
in other words do i think we should be
spending that money yes uh-huh of course
is it worth it of course it's worth it
it's part of culture
if we're going to stop that let's stop
parents teaching children manners
it may not save us any money
but it's a procedure that we could stop
let's stop teaching our children please
and thank you
it's the same thing
or caring for one another or dialing
9-1-1 when you see a man having heart
failure
do we not make that call because it
might be a toll call
how do you stop
the endowment
of the arts for the the youth of this
country mr kennedy said it better than
anybody
our children
that's our greatest natural resource
and if we if we're doing it for a ballet
company that happens to be in des moines
and they need some revenue i would maybe
get into a discussion about how to deal
with that
but generically it's a very tough call
you can't generalize i don't think you
can do that but you should recognize
that government that has the answers
needs a little sensitivity
they need a sense of humor and they need
to face the fact that we're talking
about human beings here
they become numbers on a bill that goes
through the senate
and they forget that what's behind that
are human beings that are going to bring
to our children a greater future
we should examine that from that point
of view
go ahead i'm going to get in trouble any
minute now
well let me there's a bunch of questions
about
your breakup with dean martin well why
don't we talk about lindbergh landing in
paris it's the same thing
can you finally reveal what caused it
the breakup he was too tall
but you wore slim heels right
but
that's that's a question i want to save
do you remember what i told you about
before the maryland on wall question
here it is
that's it okay
i won't even ask though you ask him
[Laughter]
no i will not no i won't i won't reply
to that no marilyn monroe no question no
matter what jobs
go ahead come on bud you're on
you know you're supposed to answer
questions give me a little time
well you're editing
he's picking the ones that he wants to
know
what was your thoughts what were your
thoughts and feelings when you just
walked on stage for the first night of
damn yankees this is a fan of yours from
for many years sandy
uh the only way i can answer that is to
tell you that it was a rush and an
adrenaline
that i thought was that night
i had it again yesterday at the matinee
after my 57th performance the rush and
the adrenaline is the same if you come
to see the show two weeks from now
the rush is going to be the same it was
something my dad had told me about that
he couldn't expound on
uh i told someone at the reception
earlier that i had i had played the
palladium and i asked my dad and my mom
to come to england with me to see me
play the palladium
and they were there that first night
when i appeared for her majesty the
queen and unlike
ever happening in the royal family after
i did two and a half hours by myself on
stage her majesty stood and applauded as
did the audience and i went back to my
dressing room and i said to my dad well
it doesn't get better than that
he said it does if you play broadway
and opening night of damn yankees i knew
what he meant
and i heard in my soul
his voice
and he said now you got it
that's the only way i can explain
what was it like working with igmar
bergman in the seventh seal
did igmar bergman make a film the
seventh seal i don't know i wasn't in it
i think i remember my body of work i was
not in the goddamn seventh seal
what was it like not being in the
seventh what was it like not being in it
a joy to behold
[Laughter]
tell us what you think about television
coverage of the o.j simpson trial
i think that two people are dead
and they're ignored
and they don't have a show
i think that's wrong
i think it's wrong and i think it's
tasteless
i think it's money-making
it's money-grubbing
i'm ashamed of the media that's doing it
i think i'm doubly ashamed of those that
watch it
[Applause]
as satan and
damn yankees do you think any of today's
major politicians have made a deal with
the devil
if they did they'd be better
[Applause]
you mentioned that
[Laughter]
you need
longer answers
hey i can i can i can
i can do an hour in the next five
minutes i promise you
uh you mentioned your problems with the
press
when did they start and why did they
start
well it's a generalization and when i
mention uh my problems with the press i
shouldn't be generic about that either
it was the two percent or the four
percent or the six percent
that didn't do their homework and or
they weren't true journalists
if you were asked something about
a film and or your lifestyle and you
answered them they're not only holding a
tape recorder but they're also making
notes and then you're misquoted
you know you're dealing with a
non-professional
now conversely
edward r murrow never needed notes
he just talked to you
and he then transmitted the information
impeccably so i make very very clear
i've never been
generically opposed
i've just been opposed to those that
don't belong in the racket i think that
i am as disturbed
not because someone in the press doesn't
belong in it but i'm more disturbed to
the fact that there's a qualified
individual that can't get a job
so they're doing a double whammy they're
not good at what they're doing and
they're hurting people
same thing in our business i want the i
want credible people doing the work that
they should be doing
whatever happened to jerry's orphans
they got a lot of press a couple of
years ago but not much recently have you
and they reached some kind of quiet
rapprochement have they lost steam what
i haven't the faintest idea where they
are
i didn't know they were here when they
were
i have no idea where they've gone
and that's of no consequence
nothing will stop what i need to do
that i work all year long to prepare for
labor day
no splinter group will stop me
nothing can stop me
other than the beat of my heart
and that won't even stop me
you mentioned your online interviews do
you use a computer and are you
personally online
no i don't use a computer
i am who i am with
i wrote a piece once for the uh
american medical association asked the
writers guild
very often to write pieces for their
their uh jama
and some years back i wrote a piece
called i am who i'm with
and it was very interesting in re
reading it
i found so much about myself as you all
do when you write something
and i found that when i'm with someone
who is
forthright
i am equally as forthright
when i'm someone who has great
credentials i feel like i do too
if i'm with someone who i believe
doesn't really want to be there they
lose me
if i think that they're not qualified i
feel unqualified
if they're warm i'm equally as warm if
they're sensitive i'm sensitive if
they're cold i can be chilling
if they're hostile i can be hostile
i usually wait to see who i'm with
before i allow my personality to show
its face
and most all people do that did you ever
say good morning to somebody that said
get the hell out of the way
never
jesus i didn't know how smart i was
uh leaving myself aside of course okay
who's the funniest man you've ever known
charlie chaplin
charlie chaplin was
and will always be
the forerunner
and the magician of great great humor
he was a great great musician he was a
brilliant ballet dancer
he was an impeccable mime he was an
extraordinary talent
he was a brilliant man
and he taught most of us
not what to do but what we shouldn't do
he was
impeccable well you've often been called
the heir to charlie chaplin's mantle i
know what i'm saying
do you see as your heirs
i think anybody that that does comedy
and cares about it
and cares what it does
for example there's a
there's a man amongst you today
that came up to me and said jerry i want
to shake your hand and thank you
because when i was a small boy
my life as a young man was traumatized
he didn't go into the why of that
but he said because of your films i
lived through that period
and i thank you for that
well anyone who does what i do
and recognizes that you can have that
kind of influence on a human being
the heirs to what i do are people who
care
deeply about what they do
and recognize their responsibility
that's who i would like to have as heirs
as it were
uh looking further into the future how
do we fill the proposed 500 new tv
channels that may be coming is a
hallmark hall of fame
in our future
well if today's television broadcasting
and programming is any indication of how
we're going to fill the 500 new
television channels if we're talking
about
high definition television and the new
support that that's going to need and
the technology is going to bring
i think we're going to need product but
i could tell you facetiously that all we
need is seven or eight murders during
the course of a year and we'll fill 500
channels
facetiously of course
why do you call your three-year-old
daughter danielle
your miracle child
well we don't have the time for me to
tell you about my daughter
she's the she's the heir in my lungs
and
she's she's what daddies have with
little girls i had a lot of sons and i
was always told during those years
where do you have a girl and i'd say you
can't love anything more than you love
your sons no
watch
she's a miracle baby because she knows
exactly what's happening she's brilliant
and she's my daughter
and she looks at my film or she looks at
something that i'm doing on television
and she puts her arms around my neck
and she says i like this daddy better
that daddy is silly
i like this daddy better
i haven't got the time to get into that
nor do you
do you still play the drums and did you
bring them along
[Music]
i'd give my soul to know who wrote that
since its anonymity at its
at its fiercest
no no comment brought drums along
everyone wants to do a straight line
you're not the only one you know
go ahead
if you couldn't do comedy
what career would you choose
surgery
if i could heal by doing the work that
dr michael debakey does i would have
liked to have done that
i love when people say what do you want
them to say about you after you're gone
and my answer is simple say it now
i'd like to hear what you
think when i'm gone i don't particularly
care what anybody says
that's why i want those eulogy stores
i'll make a fortune
would you give us a quote lady
[Music]
[Applause]
is it true
that eddie murphy is playing you in the
remake of the nutty professor
why
no he's not playing me he's doing the
character the lead character in the
nutty professor
the remake
which i'm the executive producer of
and why eddie murphy because he's box
office and because he's going to be
wonderful and it's a marvelous idea
eddie murphy will be 400 pounds
and he's battling obesity whereas in the
original we were battling the insanity
of the little professor
this is a marvelous script it's a
marvelous idea and it will probably be
very successful
are you a fan of jim carrey's would you
consider working with him
absolutely i think he's brilliant he's
probably the brightest young visual
comic to come along in 40 years i think
he's brilliant and if there's a project
where we can work together i think it
would be wonderful
you prefer them to me
oh indeed oh god yeah i got an
electrician joke was i mean that was no
why who do you think
is the funniest politician today
and why
that'll take a lot of thought
robert dornan
[Laughter]
is is about as funny as it gets
and i have no reason other than just
watching him carry on
i think he's hysterical
doesn't he have a vhs
doesn't he ever see what he does
i mean he really looks like a cartoon
character screaming and the only thing
missing is smoke coming out of his nose
i just don't understand
but that's the only opinion i have
sorry to wake you bud
what do you think of
president clinton's administration so
far
are you asking me as a professional
performer or are you asking me as a
citizen of this country
both both as a professional performer i
think that uh president clinton is doing
the very best he possibly can as a
citizen in this country we're talking
about our president of the united states
i don't believe in doing jokes about
them i don't believe in any way
demeaning the presidency i respect the
office of the man and i respect that i
care about what happens to him
as every american should
he's taken enough lumps
let him do the job he's supposed to do
[Applause]
why did you choose muscular dystrophy as
your cause
i did not choose it nor have i ever
answered that question
the important thing is that i do it the
why is of no consequence
okay yes
now before we get to the last question
okay we have a couple of gifts for you
one is a
certificate of appreciation
excuse me for being with us today
thank you
the other is uh
a national press club mug
to keep you awake during performances
or to help you raise more money for
muscular thank you bro i appreciate that
very much i shall keep that as a
treasure and i want you all to know that
i appreciate the fact that you let me
come here today it means a great deal to
me i'm really delighted to have been
with you and i thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
last question you are known worldwide
for your uh impressions imitations
could you please
give us one impression of jerry lewis
for us
coming here as a speaker is free
damn yankees is three hours by the metro
liner i'll show you all the jerry you
want to see
thank you
thank you thank you jerry and
we all recognize that
he did us a great honor by coming down
as he says monday's his only day off and
he took the time to
come down from new york and spend it
with us and for that we're very
appreciative
and grateful and we're also appreciative
and grateful
for all of you in the audience for
coming
good afternoon
[Applause]
[Music]
jerry lewis will perform on broadway in
damn yankees until september when the
show begins a six-month national tour
[Music]